stell dir vor jemand fragt sich was ist
das überhaupt geld ist doch einfach
denkst du da gibt es nicht viel zu sagen
oder doch als papier ist es wertlos und
doch verrückter weise ist es das
wertvollste auf der welt über geld kann
man sich viele gedanken machen
mit geld kannst du alles kaufen zu jeder
zeit an jedem beliebigen ort
es ist wie ein zaubermittel mit
magischen kräften
wenn man diese kraft erst mal kennen
gelernt hat kann man nicht genug davon
besitzen
um an geld zu kommen schrecken die
menschen vor nichts zurück sie leihen
sich geld bauen fabriken stellen waffen
her und töten anderen viele überlassen
begeisterte geld den kriegführenden weil
sie hoffen nach dem krieg mehr geld zu
haben
[Musik]
bei geld hört jede freundschaft auf da
geht es ganz genau zu nichts darf
verloren gehen
du hast angst um jeden cent
je mehr geld du hast desto besser ist
dein leben
deshalb möchte jeder viel haben mehr als
der andere
denn ohne geld bist du nichts
wie sehr du es brauchst weißt du erst
wenn du keins hast ohne geld hast du
kein bett zu nacht du brauchst es um
hunger und durst zu stillen oder undicht
zu amüsieren
jeder will geld einsammeln durch zins
und zinseszins hofft man wächst es wie
von alleine wird mehr und mehr mit
wachsendem reichtum wächst auch die
macht eine verfügbarkeit die sich die
menschen früher nur bei gott vorstellen
konnten
je mehr man über das wesen des geldes
nachdenkt desto unklarer werden die
gedanken desto rätselhafter das geld
der berliner philosoph georg simmel hat
im jahr 1900 ein buch darüber
veröffentlicht philosophie des geldes
single lebte damals in berlin und fragte
sich wieso die stadt so schnell groß
geworden ist
er kam zu dem schluss das rasante
wachstum beruht auf nichts anderem als
aufgeld simmel hatte beobachtet wie die
menschen in die stadt strömen und alles
tun um an geld zu kommen
sie arbeiten viel verdienen mühsam ihr
geld und kaufen mit dem geld so viel wie
möglich
simmel beobachtete wie die ruhelose
fiebern der geldgierige menschenmasse
tag und nacht in der großstadt unterwegs
ist sie lässt sich von den glitzernden
einkaufsstraßen mit ihrem aufreizenden
licht reklamen und überquellenden
kaufhäusern faszinieren
die menschen dachte sie will wissen dass
geld ein mittel ist mit dem man sich
immer neue wünsche erfüllen kann
in den kaufhäusern werden ständig neue
waren angeboten
immer mehr wird käuflich alles zur ware
durch dieses ständige kaufen und
verkaufen vermehrt sich das geld wie von
selbst
der kampf ums geld meinte simmel prägt
den charakter
alle sind ständig auf der hut müssen
sich laufend informieren
der konkurrenzkampf ist unbarmherzig
herr entfesselt kriegs und sieges frohe
instinkte und erfordert von jedem hohe
aufmerksamkeit blitzschnelle reaktionen
wie kommen andere zu geld an welcher
stelle stehe ich in der rangliste der
verdienende wer viel geld verdienen will
muss seine ganze energie in den verstand
legen muss komplizierte mathematische
operationen durchführen umfangreiche
gedanken systeme entwickeln
warum wurde das geld überhaupt erfunden
simmels antwort ist einfach geld
erleichtert den austausch von dingen
tauschen erfüllt eine nur wunsch des
menschen den besitz zu vermehren wenn
zwei beim geben und nehmen ihren vorteil
sehen
tauschen sie geld erleichtert den güter-
tausch als preis zeigt es den wert jedes
zu tauschenden dinges an fixiert die
höhe seines vergleichswertes in zahlen
die dinge brauchen nicht mehr zum
tauschen mitgeschleppt werden das geld
trägt die vergleichswerte zu den dingen
hin
geld ist ein festes werteversprechen das
überall und zu jeder zeit gegen
wirtschaftsgüter eingelöst werden kann
wir vertrauen darauf es ist das
fundament unserer gesellschaft deshalb
werden diebstahl raub und das fälschen
gesetzliche zahlungsmittel verfolgt und
streng bestraft
im tauschgeschäft werden aus begehrten
dingen wirtschaftlicher güter wenn die
war gut ist und das geld einen stabilen
wert hat dann besiegelt das
tauschgeschäft einen gerechten ausgleich
das ist das ideal doch simmels scharfen
blick entging nicht dass tauschgeschäft
lebt gerade davon dass jeder einen
größeren vorteil haben will als der
anderen an friedlichen ringen um den
besten tausch versucht jeder dem anderen
das gefühl zu geben er sei im vorteil
in wirklichkeit hat der der das geld hat
immer einen vorsprung bei harten
verhandlungen muss der der verkaufen
will
in der regel nachgeben
ja gut aber macht es nochmal auf dem
zettel gedruckt die kostet 8 90
einem aktion sich kosten diese erste
dazu hat junge leute die heute mit 950
damit muss man bitteschön kardashian
j
helle von 12
im geldgeschäft flacht das gefühl für
den mitmenschen ab der sachverstand muss
mobil bleiben darf sich nicht festlegen
das geld verdienen wird zum fixpunkt im
leben des finanzjongleurs denn der kampf
ums geld ist grausam ohne grausam sein
zu wollen
es geht sachlich zu aber ohne
persönliche bindungen zählen während des
wettkampfes nicht außer betrug ist jedes
gewaltlose mittel erlaubt das streben
nach geld gelangt nie an ein ende
erreicht der mensch mit geld einen
angestrebten zweck taucht ein neuer auf
unbegrenzt verwendbar werden das geld
und das geschäft mit dem geld
schließlich zum selbstzweck ohne jede
rücksicht
hier haben sich die banken eine welt
geschaffen eine relativ abgeschottete
welt geschaffen
wie pervers funktioniert hier wurden
junge leute gezüchtet kann man sagen die
banken haben sich diese anfang
20-jährigen reingezogen junge menschen
die bereit sind an ihre grenzen zu gehen
die bereit sind alles zu geben vollgas
zu geben bin jung jeder junge mensch
möchte an seine grenzen gehen und wenn
ich als arbeitgeber ihnen jetzt diese
grenzen soweit stecke dass ich ihn mit
millionenbudgets aus starte mit sehr
großen gehältern in dieser größenordnung
ausstattung davon aber von ihm verlange
dass er 18 stunden am tag 7 tage die
woche vollgas gibt natürlich kommst du
auch zu exzessen und die banken haben
genau diese jungen leute gebraucht die
bereit waren volles tempo zu gehen und
40 jährige
der hätte gesagt ihr habt nicht mehr
alle latten am zaun ich muss auch mal
heim zur familie oder hasen auch noch
gemäht werden da funktioniert das nicht
je mehr das geld sei eine substanzielle
form verliert und zur bloßen
recheneinheit wird desto mehr breitete
sich aus die tauschgeschäfte werden
schneller abgewickelt die beträge
beweglicher das kursierende geld kann im
bruchteil einer sekunde überall auf der
welt sein
der intellekt muss die geldströme völlig
selbstlos betrachtet
er wird für simmel zum instrument im
dienste des geldes degradiert
auch ein bisschen drüber um auch mal
ganze einzuschätzen ist es jetzt
wirklich der zirkulierende geldstrom
bestimmt das tempo des lebens jeder
eingriff ist mit größter beschleunigung
abzuwickeln an dem zentralen finanz
kloten pumpen wird massenhaft geld in
kürzester zeit durch die größte zahl von
händen gesagt bei stark schwankenden
kursen kann der wert des geldes
jederzeit die fürchterlichsten einbußen
deshalb muss man stets auf der lauer
seien rasch zugreifen und wieder
abstoßen
die angst sitzt jede minute
dollar zu verkaufen dann ist die größere
und dann irgendwann bleibt der dollar
stehen die perspektive ohne warten sie
ab und an geht er wieder hoch sondern
werden die ersten höhe und sagen okay
jetzt muss jemand verlust nehmen der
erste und damit bei jedem nacheinander
die schmerzgrenze erreicht man musste
diese kettenreaktion wasser manchmal
auch sieht nur panik das eben viele
leute dieselbe position haben und aus
ihrer position raus gewesen sich glatt
stellen sollen dann die das ding eben
doppelt zum stehen
und da muss man eben sehen dass man
entweder wenn wir auf derselben seite
waren dass man frühzeitig raus gehen
oder eben diese panik ausnutzt
mit den virtuellen geldströmen so simmel
wächst die kreditwirtschaft geld wird in
immer größeren mengen verliehen die
schulden kurve steigt und steigt der
wachsende schuldenberg lehnt zunehmend
die wirtschaft und spalte die
gesellschaft in arm und reich
geld an sich als tauschmittel es erst
mal nichts böses nur in dem moment wo
ist zu sehr zum hort mittel wird wo es
zu sehr gebunkert werden kann und damit
natürlich auch macht erhält in dem
moment wird geld gefährlich und das
erleben in diesen tagen wo immer mehr
geld sich bei immer weniger leuten
zusammen bald und die dadurch sehr viel
macht erhalten
während die große masse der menschen
immer weniger und vielleicht sogar
schulden hat und damit in die
abhängigkeit gerät und das ist eine
fehlallokation des geldes kommt wird zu
sehen auf einer stelle gehortet und da
verliert das geld seinen eigentlichen
aufgaben eben nicht als blut der
wirtschaft als blut der menschen leben
circa miteinander zu fließen
mangelndes geld und wachsender
geldbedarf geben den takt vor
das geld wird zum maß aller dinge wie
ein naturgesetz beherrschtes die
lebenszeit
immer mehr wird dem geld unterworfen
das herzustellende dingen wie der mensch
der es herstellt leistung und
gegenleistung besitzen keinen wert an
sich
sie sind nur tausch werte
der sachlich abwägende fabrikbesitzer
interessiert sich nicht für die
individualität seines arbeiters und der
nicht für die produkte der arbeiter
sieht nur die mühe die es kostet um
seinen lohn zu bekommen nur die menge an
geld die er für seinen schweiß bekommt
interessiert ihn die wirklichkeit hat
für das seelenleben immer weniger
bedeutung
sie wird zur durststrecke auf dem weg
zum geld
das geld so folgert himmel löst alle
dinge aus ihrem ursprünglichen
zusammenhang
die vorstellung von einer geordneten
einheitlichen welt stürzt ein
alles gerät in bewegung alles wird ware
nichts besteht mehr für sich wer viel
geld hat glaubt damit die ordnung der
dinge selbst bestimmen zu können
deshalb will jeder möglichst viel geld
haben
[Applaus]
doch das ständige geld verdienen müssen
zerstört die gewachsene lebensform die
gemüt volle vertraute umgebung zerfällt
einst hatten die menschen ihre einfache
existenz auf dem land aufgegeben um den
persönlichen zwang des feudalherren zu
entkommen
die stadt versprach ihnen freiheit mit
geld das leben zu genießen
ein beispiel mehr als 20 jahre
arbeiteten diese kroatischen frauen in
deutschland
sie kamen in der hoffnung später in
ihrer heimat ein besseres leben führen
zu können
sie wurden bitter enttäuscht dass acht
arische prinzip seinen vorteil nicht im
gerechten tausch sondern im raum zu
suchen hatte ihre illusion zerstört
ihnen blieb nur die fabrik um weiter
geld zu verdienen
wer nichts mehr zu verlieren hat so
simmel wird verführt das risiko zu
erhöhen
verzweifelt setzt der verlierer alles
aufs spiel
jeglicher sachverstand der auf der
berechnung von verlust
wahrscheinlichkeit beruht setzt
vollkommen aus alle objektiven faktoren
sind dem spieler völlig gleichgültig
das geht so weit dass sie schlussendlich
nicht mehr schlafen können nur noch an
die gewinne denken dann die verluste
endlich bin monatelang aufgewacht mitten
aus dem schlaf und haben nun hat den
roulette übergehen wird wie es gemacht
hat und ich war pitschnass sind und
meine mama nicht so schön ich bin ja
nicht im casino und also das ist
tatsächlich das nicht so viel platz
seinem leben das für nichts anderes mehr
da ist der unerschütterliche glaube des
spielers ein privater gott könne es nur
gut mit dem meinen macht ihn zur
leichten beute bestatters der bis zu 90
prozent der einnahmen kassiert er
profitiert von den menschen ihren seelen
nicht glauben wollen dass sie die sucht
nach geld im griff hat und die gier
jetzt hab ich gewonnen ich habe meinen
einsatz von mir aus 100 prozent
verdoppelt jetzt müsste ich vom verstand
her sagen ich höre auf
und das prinzip der gewiefte
geschäftsmann nicht daher spielt der
kann nicht aufhören
das heißt so eiskalt ist keiner zu sagen
okay ich habe jetzt meine 10.000 jetzt
nein
jetzt kommen die gier nach mehr auch das
ist ja nur der lauf heute habe ich glück
es ist tatsächlich so schweizer irgendwo
kommt sehr aber ich habe das glück ich
setze und er geht raus in die taschen
leer sind
nur wer sich nicht von der gier
hinreißen lässt und konsequent jegliches
risiko vermeidet hat eine minimale
chance zu gewinnen
hier persönlich ist es gelungen aus dem
glücksspiel roulette ein intellektuelles
geschicklichkeitsspiel zu machen
einen kampf gegen die maschine durch
überlegte besonnene einsätze zum
richtigen zeitpunkt das timing ist
wichtig und deswegen spielt der zufall
und das glück eine immer geringere rolle
wenn ein bisschen glück noch hinzu kommt
umso besser aber die spielweise ist
nicht auf dem glück aufgebaut sondern
auf den gesetzen des zufalls um schnell
an geld zu kommen bieten manche das
intimste zum verkauf an
die sexuelle dienstleistung ist frei von
persönlicher beziehung das klima
geschäftlich die begegnung förmlich der
käufliche genuss ist schnell bei der
hand und wird sachlich abgewickelt beide
seiten betrachten sich als bloße mittel
nach der transaktion ist alles erledigt
himmel meint die prostitution
verdeutlicht wie kein anderes gewerbe
das wesen der geldwirtschaft ich hab
mich dann selbstständig gemacht im
dienstleistungsgewerbe wo mir eigentlich
auch irgendwie sehr viel spaß gemacht
hat ich habe durch diesen beruf sehr
viele leute kennengelernt und natürlich
viel geld verdient ja das war einfach
ein schönes gefühl dieses geld zu
verdienen dieses geld zu haben und
immerzu wiesen morgen verdiene ich ja
wieder welches das geld wurde dann immer
mehr immer mehr immer mehr und das war
halt schön ich habe ja meinem leben noch
nie so viel geld gesehen wie hier in
frankfurt ja ich konnte mir auf einmal
alles kaufen ohne dass meine eltern
irgendwie mir über die schulter geguckt
haben und haben gesagt das machst du
jetzt mal nicht ich hab einfach gemacht
was ich wollte
prostitution hat es seit dem altertum in
fast allen gesellschaften gegeben aber
erst in der modernen anonymen großstadt
wurde sie zum massenphänomen zu beginn
des letzten jahrhunderts verbot der
staat die prostitution auf der straße
und erlaubte sie nur noch in speziellen
modellen
dort herrschten fabrik mäßige zustände
die damen mussten im akkord arbeiten und
bis zu 100 freie am tag abfertigen
[Musik]
egal ob die frau fraglich ist ob die
gesundes ist egal hauptsache billion
alles im billigen massenkonsum von sechs
arbeiten der staat und der bordell
kapital ist eng zusammen der staat
verbietet das werben für prostitution
auf der straße der clevere betreiber
richtet feste arbeitsplätze in
geschlossenen häusern ein für die teure
miete des zimmers muss die prostituierte
hart arbeiten
sexarbeit wird immer härter dieser job
macht geldgierig wirklich das ist
einfach so das ist wie eine droge wie
eine sucht du du bist krank wenn
irgendwo bist und denkst poetischen wie
der welt vorliegen können du hast gab
keine ruhe du musst unbedingt dahin ja
weil wenn man mal dieses geld verdient
hat dann dass es wahnsinn ja da will man
es natürlich immer immer wieder haben
immer wieder in der prostitution
verliert die frau ihre individuelle
besonderheit schreibzimmer sie wird
verachtet weil jeder für geld viele von
ihnen haben kann
darunter leidet ihr selbstbewusstsein
die frau muss dafür kämpfen sich nicht
selbst zu verachten
das gelingt viele nicht ihr ausweg die
flucht in eine fatale traumwelt das
leben gekostet in dem ich also abgerückt
ich war mein eigener chef
niemand hat gesagt hör auf das geld sagt
simmel hat den menschen die loslösung
von der fatalen knechtschaft auf dem
lande gebracht dafür wächst in den
städten seine abhängigkeit vom geld und
damit seine entwurzelung
er verliert den boden unter den füßen
die sicherheit und zuverlässigkeit einer
geordneten welt den halt
[Musik]
bei primitiven formen des tauschhandels
besaßen dinge die besonders seltene
haltbare eigenschaften hatten noch den
rang von geld dazu zählte vor allem das
reine goldmann glaubte die ewige feste
substanz dieses edelmetalls verleihe dem
geld einen dauerhaften zeitlosen wert
ein unverwüstliches aufbewahrungs mittel
des geldwertes zugleich war es für
soziale bedürfnisse einsetzbar der dem
material eigene glanzzeit als schmuck
die blicke auf sich und wertet die
person die ihn trägt auf aus dieser zeit
stammt die illusion gold und seltene
edelsteine sein selbst etwas wertvolles
geld gold und edelsteine vermitteln uns
ein gefühl das in der kindheit verloren
ging
ein gefühl von ruhe und sicherheit dass
jederzeit unsere wünsche erfüllen kann
dem schenken wir unser vertrauen
wer gold und edelsteine besitzt der
strahlt erfolg und macht aus wer ein
solches stück erwirbt der betet es
hinrainer ehrfurcht an verehrtes um
seiner selbst willen als besitze er
damit etwas von der allmacht und güte
gottes
wichtig ist oft dass der kunde den der
den ring oder das collier oder das
armband mit einem großen stein kauft
dass der stein auch oft die substanz
darstellt das heißt das was was ihn
letztendlich verführt weil ein stein ist
was kann etwas sehr sehr geheimnisvolles
seien gerade die farb- steine gerade das
was an geschichte auch mitgeliefert wird
und auch da ist wiederum der verkauf
gefragt das was der der professionelle
verkäufer dem den kunden letztendlich an
an positiven guten gedanken mitgeben
kann über ein stück über ein stein auf
und die steine sind letztendlich über
jahrmillionen entstanden unter großen
großem druck
wo nicht das geld sondern das heil der
seele als endzweck betrachtet wird sagt
simmel gehen manche den weg bewusster
armut sie geben ihren besitz auf und
schwelgen im ideal fälliger bedürfnis
losigkeit die entsagen den halten dem
verführerischen charakter des geldes
stand sie stehen dem irdischen
gleichgültig gegenüber ohne innere
beziehung ohne genuss
[Musik]
sie glauben in der armut besitzen sie
den reinsten feinsten extrakt der dinge
meint simmel ihnen gehört die welt in
einem höheren sinn
ohne besonders darauf gerichteten willen
[Musik]
geld kann immer sehr schnell zum
selbstzweck werden als würden wir haben
zumal börse anschaue oder sonst hier in
frankfurt im umgang mit geld das ich
doch sehr viele menschen die als in
zweck das geld haben sehen das geld
sehen und darauf hinarbeiten frage mich
was soll einer mit millionen fiktiv
irgendwo auf einer bank soll das dann
wird stilisiert sich das zum gott
[Musik]
simmel lobt die freiheit die die
geldwirtschaft hervorgebracht hat doch
er sieht auch die gefahren
viele reagieren auf die wechselnden
nerven reize auf das maßlose genuss
leben mit einer blasiertheit die
schließlich überhaupt keine sinnvolle
reaktion mehr hervorbringt wenn das geld
alles relativiert hat dann verschwinden
auch die ideellen werte aus dem
blickfeld
je mehr einer hat desto mehr kommt er in
eine welt hinein war der kann in eine
welt hinein kommen die ja so einer
paradiesischen zustand in ihm auslöst
als er kann dessen was er will trinken
kann es ja vornehmen irgendwo mit ihren
wo eingeladen von prominenten leuten
sieht sondern kann die gefahr besteht
allerdings darin dass sie sich dabei
selbst verhindert sie der mensch fühlt
sich darum ende findet erst dann oder
kann sich wohl fühlen wenn er sein
eigenes entfaltet und das entfaltet man
nicht primär durch geld ja ich würde
fast sagen dann entfaltet ist durch
armut durch verzicht weit ihn auf
gewissen konsum die man durch geld
erreicht
denn dadurch wenn die eigenen
fähigkeiten fantasiert wie geht und dann
schaut nach was ist mehr drin und was
muss eben zu leben und das gibt im
endeffekt eine befriedigung
die bedürfnis losen christlichen seelen
fühlen sich vom irdischen ballast
befreit wie vögel die zum himmel streben
wohin sie auch fliegen sie tragen nichts
mit sich außer ihre flügel
sie besitzen nicht und glauben alles zu
besitzen
reich an inneren gütern leben sie in
hoher freude fröhlichkeit ist ihre
speise ein bedürfnis loser uhr
kommunismus muss das frühe christentum
gewesen sein
mein zimmer kein begehrlich der an der
natur raubbau gibt das geld regiert die
welt wie die uhr schreibzimmer es reißt
die gegenstände aus ihrer für sich sein
denn ruhe unterwirft sie dem vergleich
mit anderen relativiert alles feste sich
selbst gleiche substanzielle und löst es
in funktion kraft bewegung auf
konstatiert simmel
auch die vorstellung dass die seele eine
einheitliche substanz sei zerfällt der
moderne mensch ist zur durchgangsstation
sich ständig ändernder eindrücke
geworden
viele können mit der rasanten
entwicklung nicht mithalten
sie fühlen sich immer weniger
selbstständig und immer abhängiger
so hat der mensch immer mehr den
charakter des zirkulierenden geldes
angenommen und fühlt sich in der
fließenden geldmenge immer weniger wert
[Musik]